Ich weiss, dass mich das Virus
nicht sofort anspringt,
wenn ich den Campus verlasse - und
doch ist es ein komisches Gefühl.
Hier, in diesem Tiermarkt in Wuhan
hat alles begonnen.
Das neuartige Coronavirus sprang
vom Tier auf den Menschen über.
Anfang Dezember
wurden die ersten Infizierten
in die Spitäler der Stadt
eingeliefert.
Am 23. Januar dann der Shutdown -
die 11-Mio.-Stadt Wuhan
wurde hermetisch abgeriegelt.
Im Epizentrum der Epidemie:
zehn Schweizer.
Unter ihnen die Berner Studentin
Fabienne Blaser.
Vor der Quarantäne habe ich
den Ernst der Lage nicht realisiert.
Wir stehen in Kontakt
mit der Schweizer Botschaft.
Wir haben gehört,
dass es allenfalls Bemühungen gibt,
Schweizer aus der Gefahrenregion
evakuieren zu können.
Im Dauereinsatz
für das Schweizer Fernsehen:
China-Korrespondentin Claudia Stahel.
Diese Apotheke gehört zu jenen,
die täglich Masken erhalten,
um sie an die Bevölkerung
zu verteilen.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Schanghai.
Hier lebt
und arbeitet Claudia Stahel,
seit Sommer SRF-China-
und Ostasien-Korrespondentin.
Wir gehen jetzt ... kurz raus.
Der Kameramann, Lorenz,
hat auf dem Weg zu mir gesehen,
dass vor einer Apotheke
sehr viele Menschen Schlange stehen.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass sie
Gesichtsmasken kaufen wollen.
Wir sehen nach,
wie lang die Schlange ist
und ob sie wirklich warten.
Oh, ich muss natürlich
selbst auch eine anziehen.
Lorenz, hast du deine?
Ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass dieser Teil unten ist.
Überziehen.
Dann schauen,
dass sie bei der Nase gut sitzt.
Ich nehme noch den Rucksack mit.
Seit Ausbruch der Epidemie
arbeitet Claudia Stahel
beinahe rund um die Uhr.
Heute realisiert sie
einen Beitrag für die "Tagesschau".
Ni hao. Ni hao.
Thema:
der Maskennotstand in Schanghai.
Wuhan ist 700 km entfernt.
Doch auch hier in Schanghai -
leere Strassen.
Viele Bewohner der Stadt
sind für das chinesische Neujahrsfest
zu ihren Familien gereist.
Wer noch in der Stadt ist,
bleibt zu Hause.
Denn auch in Schanghai gibt es
über 180 Infizierte und einen Toten.
Nur in den Apotheken
herrscht Hochbetrieb.
* Stimmengewirr *
Ich war schon dreimal hier,
um Masken zu kaufen.
Jede Person
bekommt max. zehn Masken.
Ich habe keine Masken mehr bekommen.
Ich war zu spät,
sie waren schon ausverkauft.
Zum dritten Mal diese Woche.
Nächste Woche
wird es sicher besser werden.
Ich habe Vertrauen
in unsere Regierung.
Ich bin Fabienne und komme aus Bern.
Ich bin momentan in Wuhan.
Die Uni lässt uns jeden Tag Fieber
messen und die Werte einschicken.
Das muss ich in ein Online-Formular
eintragen und über WeChat versenden.
Meine Temperatur ist 36,1 °.
Das ist also kein Problem.
Vor der Quarantäne habe ich
den Ernst der Lage nicht realisiert.
Ich denke, erst ein paar Tage vorher
wurde allen langsam bewusst,
dass es wirklich nicht mehr gut ist.
Chinesische Freunde
haben mir geholfen
und mir viel Gemüse geschickt.
Oder hier beispielsweise Reis.
Hier habe ich noch mehr Gemüse.
Ziemlich viel Brokkoli und Kohl.
Noch mehr Kartoffeln.
Und das ist die Aussicht
von meinem Zimmer aus.
Man kann aus dem Zimmer rausgehen,
in die Stadt gehen, wenn man möchte.
Wahrscheinlich fahren nur
ein paar wenige Taxis. Aber ...
Ja.
Ich bringe jetzt den Abfall raus
und gehe Wasser kaufen.
Der grössere Supermarkt des Campus
ist geschlossen.
Man muss entweder
übers Internet einkaufen oder ...
... ausserhalb des Campus
zum nächsten grossen,
geöffneten Supermarkt gehen.
Im Turmgebäude werden grosse
Kanister mit Wasser verkauft.
Offenbar hat es noch genügend.
In der Situation, in der ich
jetzt bin, ist es wohl das Beste,
mein geplantes nächstes Semester
einfach aufzugeben
und möglichst schnell
nach Hause zu gehen.
Ich weiss jedoch nicht,
wann das ist.
Niemand weiss, wann Wuhan
wieder geöffnet wird.
Ich hoffe, dass ich
mithilfe der Schweizer Botschaft
schneller nach Hause komme.
Seit einer Woche organisiert die
städtische Behörde in Schanghai
täglich eine Pressekonferenz
zum Thema Coronavirus -
eine ungewöhnlich proaktive
Vorgehensweise.
* Sie spricht chinesisch. *
Is it possible to ask a question?
Kritische Fragen von Claudia Stahel,
ausweichende Antworten
der zuständigen Behörde.
Tian hat geschrieben, wir möchten
etwas wissen zum Thema Maskenmangel.
Wir möchten wissen, was sie machen,
um den zu beheben.
Konkret, weshalb es in Schanghai
nur 3 Mio. Gesichtsmasken gibt.
Wegen des Frühlingfestes sind
viele Fabrikarbeiter in den Ferien.
Wenn wieder Normalbetrieb herrscht,
können wir garantieren,
dass genug Masken
produziert werden.
Man muss sich auch bewusst sein,
weshalb eine solche Situation
eine Herausforderung ist
für die kommunistische Partei
und die Parteispitze um Xi Jingpin.
Es gibt einen Deal zwischen Partei,
Parteispitze und Bevölkerung:
Die Partei hat quasi die Aufgabe,
zu schauen,
dass es der Bevölkerung gut geht.
Dieser Deal ist natürlich in Gefahr
durch dieses Coronavirus.
Deshalb stehen sie
so stark unter Zugzwang.
Sie müssen schauen,
dass sie das in den Griff bekommen.
Und wir sind jetzt
erst am Anfang des Ganzen.
Wir wissen noch nicht,
wie es ausgehen wird.
Ich bin überzeugt,
wenn es China schafft,
diese Krise
in den Griff zu bekommen,
dann wird das garantiert als
grosse Heldengeschichte verkauft -
in China selbst
und auch gegen aussen.
"Wir sind diejenigen,
die es geschafft haben,
gemeinsam
diese Krise zu bewältigen."
Ihre Mitarbeiterin Tian ist
für Claudia Stahel unentbehrlich -
sie übersetzt die Aufnahmen
von der Pressekonferenz
und sichert den Kontakt
zu Behörden und Protagonisten.
Doch es droht Unbill.
Offenbar wird Tian jetzt
von den Behörden angegangen,
dass sie eine Bewilligung braucht,
damit sie für mich bis
zum 9. Februar weiterarbeiten darf.
Ich habe noch nichts davon gehört.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie es bei Lorenz und mir aussieht.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es noch
kommen könnte. Keine Ahnung.
126 10:08:45,840 --> 10:08:49,560
Ich habe die Bewilligung.
Mein Antrag wurde genehmigt.
Der Antrag wofür?
- Um wieder zu arbeiten.
Also, dann kannst du morgen
mitkommen in die Maskenfabrik?
Ja.
- Okay, cool.
Claudia Stahel steht
in engem Kontakt zu Pierre Gerber,
einem der zehn
eingeschlossenen Schweizer
in der Region
rund um die Stadt Wuhan.
Hallo.
- Hallo, Claudia.
Salut. Wie geht's?
- Ni hao. Ni hao.
Ich bin derzeit in Dawu,
in der Provinz Hubei in China.
Ich sitze hier fest -
zusammen mit meinem Enkel
und meiner Frau,
die aus dieser Stadt kommt.
Wir verbringen jedes Jahr
ein paar Monate in Dawu.
Wir haben hier Neujahr verbracht.
Es sieht aus,
als wären das Kontrollleute,
die irgendetwas überprüfen.
Hier links ist das Spital.
Es heisst, hier gäbe es
vier Fälle infizierter Personen.
Vier infizierte Personen
in der ganzen Stadt.
Und die Stadt hat ...
rund 60'000-70'000 Einwohner.
Das ist die Grenze von Dawu Xian,
also vom Bezirk Dawu
zum Bezirk Guangxi.
Hier gibt es eine Strassensperre,
damit man nicht
nach Guangxi fahren kann.
Damit die Menschen nicht umherreisen
und sich nicht bewegen.
Hier, im zürcherischen Forch leben
Pierre Gerbers Tochter und ihr Mann.
Witwer Pierre Gerber heiratete
vor zehn Jahren seine zweite Frau,
die Chinesin Wang Shao.
Das Coronavirus scheint v.a. für
ältere Menschen gefährlich zu sein.
Ich glaube,
er hat es etwas unterschätzt.
Vielleicht waren die Menschen
auch nicht richtig informiert.
Wir haben hier aus dem Ausland
etwas Panik gemacht.
(Journalist) Inwiefern unterschätzt?
Indem er sich
überhaupt keine Sorgen gemacht hat
und es sich jetzt anders entwickelt.
Er hat sich irgendwann überlegt,
dass es doch gefährlich
werden könnte.
Dann stellte sich die Frage,
ob er mit seiner Frau in die Schweiz
zurückkommen will ...
... oder nicht.
Der psychische Druck, den er hatte,
war erstens,
ob seine Frau mitkommen kann,
ob sie das überhaupt schaffen.
Und zweitens,
was sie mit dem Enkelkind machen.
V.a. weiss man nicht,
wie lange es dauert.
Ich finde,
das ist auch immer ein Faktor.
Wenn es nach zwei Monaten vorbei
wäre, würde man das durchstehen.
Wenn es aber sieben Monate dauert,
ist es etwas anderes.
Ich mache mir auch Sorgen
über die Nahrungsmittel.
Momentan habe es in den Supermärkten
offenbar noch viele Vorräte,
man kann noch alles kaufen.
Aber wie sieht es denn aus,
wenn es noch länger andauert?
Was immer meine Frau kauft,
wird abgekocht,
bevor wir irgendetwas essen.
Das hier ist Tofu.
And this spinach.
Das ist Spinat
und hier ... noch Schweinefilet.
Das Abendessen ist bereit.
Guten Appetit! - Thank you.
* Fabienne liest auf chinesisch. *
Ich habe
vom Plan der Deutschen gehört,
dass sie mit einem Militärflugzeug
abgeholt werden möchten.
Das Problem ist, dass man eigen-
ständig zum Flughafen kommen muss.
Niemand weiss, wie man das schafft.
Der Flughafen ist 1 1/2 Autostunden
von hier entfernt.
Und ja ...
Eigentlich
fahren keine Fahrzeuge mehr.
Es gibt nur noch spezielle Taxis
für jede Region.
Zu Fuss würde es
etwa 10 Std. dauern. Und ja ...
Ich weiss es nicht genau.
Ich will heute rausgehen
und im Büro der Uni nachsehen,
ob jemand vor Ort ist,
um ihnen mitzuteilen,
dass ich das nächste Semester
nicht hier verbringen werde.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Vielleicht
können sie auch nach Hause gehen.
Sie wissen es noch nicht,
aber sie möchten auch gehen.
In meiner Aufnahme haben sie gesagt,
sie müssen jetzt auch filmen
für die Medien in ihrer Heimat.
Aus Schweizer Sicht sieht das
vielleicht nicht speziell aus.
Aber für Wuhan-Verhältnisse
ist das wirklich leer.
Fabienne Blaser will Wuhan
so schnell wie möglich verlassen.
Hallo. Hier ist noch der Kameramann.
Vielen Dank für all das,
was du mir geschickt hast.
Der 27-jährigen Berner Studentin
setzt der Alltag in Quarantäne
langsam zu.
Claudia Stahel
teilt ihr einen direkten Kontakt
zur Schweizer Botschaft mit.
Er hat mir gesagt,
ich könne dir
seine WeChat-Kontaktnummer geben.
Sie seien halt ziemlich auf Trab,
müssen vieles organisieren,
deshalb haben sie kaum Zeit,
sich bei dir
und bei Pierre zu melden.
Ich habe auch angerufen
und sie meinten,
ich müsse halt ... geduldig sein
und sie seinen in Kontakt
mit den Nachbarländern.
Ich schicke dir gleich
seinen WeChat-Kontakt.
Und ja ...
Gut. Tschüss.
- Tschüss, tschau.
Die Zeitverschiebung in Schanghai
beträgt 7 Std.
Sind die Nachrichtensendungen
des Schweizer Fernsehens bedient,
ist bei Claudia Stahel
schon wieder früher Morgen
und die Recherchen
für den nächsten Tag beginnen.
Vor dem Fertigstellen des Beitrags -
ein Gang in die Shoppingmall,
um Kaffeekapseln und Lebensmittel
zu besorgen.
Das ist jetzt auch neu.
Dieses Desinfektionsmittel
enthält Bleiche,
deshalb stinkt es auch ein wenig.
Es soll bloss nicht
mit den Augen in Kontakt kommen.
Neuerdings, offenbar seit heute,
wird man hier kontrolliert,
um in die Mall zu kommen.
Die Öffnungszeiten wurden
aufgrund des Coronavirus angepasst.
Es schliesst bereits um 18 Uhr
und ...
... jetzt haben wir 18.15 Uhr -
wir sind also etwas zu spät.
Is it possible to give it to them?
- Yes.
Oh, super. Xièxiè.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, bye-bye.
Wir vertreiben uns die Zeit
ein wenig
mit dem Fitnessprogramm
von Helsana+.
Heute ist Donnerstag,
der 30. Januar.
Meine Frau hat gerade
im WeChat gelesen,
dass in Dawu Privatautos
nicht mehr fahren dürfen.
D.h., was wir gestern gemacht haben,
ist heute nicht mehr möglich.
Nur noch offizielle Fahrzeuge
sind erlaubt -
also Krankenwagen,
Feuerwehr Polizei,
Erlaubt ist es auch für Leute,
die eine Fieberkontrolle machen
oder sonst etwas überprüfen müssen.
Eine Freundin von uns
arbeitet im Spital.
Sie hat uns gerade mitgeteilt,
dass es in Dawu
jetzt 16 infizierte Personen gibt.
16.
Hier haben wir
vier leere Wasserflaschen.
Weil heute
und auch in den kommenden Tagen
der Verkehr auf den Strassen
nicht erlaubt ist,
werden wir keinen Nachschub mehr
erhalten.
Betreffend Wasser
werden uns mit Leitungswasser
zufriedengeben müssen.
Wir werden das abkochen
und so ausreichend Wasser haben.
Jetzt kommt auch Bobo
zu seinem Mittagessen.
Guten Appetit, Bobo!
- Danke.
Ich habe eine E-Mail
der Schweizer Botschaft erhalten.
Dies betrifft
die mögliche Evakuierung
von Schweizern aus Wuhan.
Das Risiko, auf dem Weg
hängenzubleiben, sei hoch.
Und es wäre auch möglich,
dass man nicht mehr
zurück zum Ausgangspunkt kommt,
wenn man irgendwo hängenbleibt.
Man könnte also
nicht zurück nach Dawu.
Und es ist so, dass meine Frau ...
... als chinesische
Staatsangehörige ...
... nicht mitreisen könnte.
Es wäre also nur für mich möglich.
Aufgrund dieser Situation,
auch, weil derzeit in Dawu
keine Autos fahren dürfen,
habe ich beschlossen,
in Dawu zu bleiben -
zusammen mit meiner Frau
und mit meinem Enkelkind.
Ich habe heute mit
der Schweizer Botschaft telefoniert.
Sie fragten mich als erstes,
ob ich ausreisen
und Wuhan verlassen möchte,
falls es eine
Evakuierungsmöglichkeit gibt.
Das habe ich bestätigt.
Der aktuelle Stand ist,
dass die Botschaft
noch keine Auskunft geben kann.
Es gibt noch keine Möglichkeit,
Schweizer nach Hause zu schicken.
Deshalb versuchen sie auch,
mit der französischen
und deutschen Botschaft zu arbeiten.
Denn es ist momentan schwierig,
alleine etwas zu erreichen.
Auch aufgrund
der chinesischen Regierung,
die anders beschäftigt ist.
Schanghai am Freitagmorgen.
An der Pressekonferenz vom Mittwoch
deponierte Claudia Stahel
bei der Stadtbehörde den Wunsch,
mit der Kamera bei der Produktion
von Gesichtsmasken dabei zu sein.
Flux wurde die Besichtigung eines
entsprechenden Betriebs organisiert.
Ich sitze hier neben der Frau,
die hier in Schanghai für
ausländische Medien zuständig ist.
Sie hat mir gerade erzählt,
dass dies offenbar
eine der grössten Medienreisen ist,
die sie jemals organisiert hat.
Es hätten sich
80 Medienleute angemeldet,
die Hälfte davon
chinesische Medienleute,
die andere Hälfte
ausländische Medienleute.
Ich habe keine Zeit, mir
wirklich Gedanken darüber zu machen,
ob ich Angst habe oder nicht.
Seit die Zahlen explodieren,
ist das Interesse
von Schweizer Seite riesig,
dass ich Berichte dazu mache.
Ich arbeite seither quasi nonstop,
setze mich mit Leuten in Verbindung,
auch über WeChat, ich recherchiere,
gehe nach draussen, um Leute zu
treffen, selbst unterwegs zu sein.
Ich stehe morgens auf und überlege,
was ich heute mache.
Es bleibt keine Zeit, zu überlegen,
ob ich Angst habe oder nicht.
Ich halte mich an die hier geltenden
Empfehlungen der Regierung.
200'000 Masken pro Tag werden hier
im 24-Std.-Schichtbetrieb produziert.
Normalerweise wird ein Grossteil
dieser Masken ins Ausland exportiert.
Jetzt bleibt die gesamte Ware
im Land.
Die Stadtregierung gibt vor,
wie viele Masken ausgeliefert werden
und wohin.
Aus den Medien habe ich gehört,
dass in der Provinz Hubei in Wuhan
ein neuartiges Virus
aufgetaucht ist.
Ich habe 2003 SARS erlebt
und 2005 die Vogelgrippe,
2008 dann die Schweinegrippe.
Darum wusste ich,
was auf uns zukommt.
Ich habe sofort alle Arbeiter und
die Kapitalgeber zusammengerufen.
Wir arbeiten 24 Std., Tag und Nacht.
Niemand kann sich derzeit ausruhen.
Hey.
Hallo.
Das wären ja super News,
wenn du gehen könntest,
wenn das klappen würde.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich dorthin komme.
Denn das ist
in einem anderen Distrikt.
Zu Fuss ist das mehr als 3 Std.
von hier entfernt.
Momentan ist es etwas schwierig, ...
... weil es nicht so einfach ist ...
... ein Auto zu organisieren.
Deshalb besteht die Angst,
dummerweise den Flug zu verpassen.
Ich weiss noch nicht genau,
wann ich fliege.
Das Wichtigste ist jetzt jedoch,
kein Fieber zu bekommen.
Sonst nehmen sie mich nicht mit.
Ich habe
einen Anruf der Botschaft erhalten,
dass ich um 17 Uhr beim
französischen Konsulat sein soll
und dass es jetzt definitiv ist.
Ich habe jetzt einen Fahrer,
der jedoch nur um 14 Uhr Zeit hat,
weil er sonst noch Leute
abholen und fahren muss.
Ich will jetzt noch richtig packen.
Heute morgen habe ich noch
gar nicht wirklich damit gerechnet,
dann kam der Anruf,
dass ich gehen kann.
Daraufhin habe ich alles
einfach in den Koffer geworfen.
Aber ... viele Sachen
nehme ich gar nicht mit,
weil ich sie
eigentlich gar nicht brauche.
Es ist der 1. Februar in Dawu.
Bobo bringt seiner Grossmutter
Tai-Chi-Übungen bei.
Wie viele Kranke
gibt es jetzt in Dawu?
54.
- 54?
Es sind also 54.
Wir haben eine Nachricht
aus dem Spital erhalten,
dass es heute weniger Eintritte gab,
als während den letzten Tagen.
Vielleicht ist das ein Zeichen,
dass die Ansteckung in Dawu,
mit den Massnahmen, die von der
Stadtregierung getroffen wurden,
vielleicht zurückgehen -
das hoffen wir auf jeden Fall.
Ich bin jetzt in einem Taxi,
gemeinsam mit zwei Personen
von den Seychellen,
die dann auch in Frankreich
in die Quarantäne kommen.
Zumindest
bin ich dort nicht so alleine.
Fabienne Blaser
konnte Wuhan gestern Abend verlassen.
Nun steht ihr noch eine zweiwöchige
Quarantäne in Südfrankreich bevor.
Pierre Gerbers Hoffnung
auf eine baldige Entspannung der Lage
hat sich indes zerschlagen.
In seinem Quartier wurde heute
ein Krankheitsfall gemeldet.
Claudia Stahel ist schon auf dem Weg
zum nächsten Dreh.
Noch gibt es keine Heldengeschichten
zu erzählen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Maria Krähenbühl - 2020